welcome one welcome all both human and
scroll welcome to the heavy spoiler show
I'm your host paulos and this video
we're breaking down secret Invasion
Episode 4 building off the back of last
week that had a meeting with Talus and
gravic about what the war could
eventually lead to we now know exactly
what the Scrolls plan is and they want
to have humanity take itself out of the
game by having us turn our weapons on
each other they're also making super
Scrolls which we'll talk about in just a
bit and it's clear that graphic wants to
take things to the extremis wanting to
flush out the trailer on his ranks this
was revealed to be Gaia and the episode
closed out with him seemingly killing
her however if you'd seen any of the
trailers and you knew what was coming
and Emilia Clarke was obviously going to
play a big role in the show also how he
watches Nick's wife got a gun and also
mysterious phone call which takes us in
episode 4.
[Music]
[Applause]
now episode 4 is titled beloved which
ties into a poem that we'll discuss in
just a bit we pick up immediately after
guy's death last week and learn that we
got a third time right because she
injected herself with a super skull
serum before Escaping The Compound the
extremacy heals her but most importantly
it shows us just how the Machine Works
contained in the reactor of the plant
this actually has two steps to it
firstly involves the DNA and then it
involves the reactor creating well a
reaction and it's also important to bear
in mind that guy took the memories from
the scientist which is how she got it to
work and it might help her destroy it
down the line now from here we go to the
title sequence before we then jump to
2012. as I'm sure you know this is the
air that the Battle of New York took
place in Avengers and we joined Nick
Fury in Paris in the aftermath of it
it's still headline news so we can
imagine that this is taking place
recently after that whole battle went
down he's wearing his classic trench
cone tail neck from the film though his
beard is slightly longer the pair
discussed the poet Raymond Cara who's
the star known as someone that
revitalized the American short story and
this happened during the 1980s as Varys
says his poems are short with a punch
line and the pair discussed the poem
title late fragment now this poem itself
actually has a lot of meaning and it
ties in how we look back at the author
himself late fragment was the final
palmy Road just before his death and he
asks himself if he's fulfilled his
ultimate goal in life that is to feel
beloved which of course ties in the
title of the episode and it also has a
man's ring that he has Carver died at
just the age of 50 and this has been
seen as the author still finding that he
lived a full life even though it was cut
short Carver sadly passed away from lung
cancer and this poem itself was actually
inscribed directly on his grave it
really gives insight to the poet facing
his final days but he felt at peace and
also fulfilled avara and fury Bond over
this with a pair once more touching
hands last week they had something
similar with the documents on drakov she
passed to him and it's clear that the
pair are now getting ready to spend
their lives together now in the present
we cut the Barra in a church watching a
choir sing the song Deep River this is
about the hope that Peace and Freedom
will one day be felt and it's something
that's been adopted by groups facing
persecution it of course represents how
Vara and the rest of the Scrolls feel
however they're clearly willing to kill
whoever they can to get what they want
which now includes Fury joined in the
house of the Lord we watch as a hit
sorted by scroll Roddy and a we're in a
church mate where's your respect now
last week in the case of Nick's wife
there was that phone call that had
everyone wondering what was going on I
just assumed it was Pagan who was being
used as a proxy and didn't really go too
far into it on the video however you fox
kept telling me it was Rory and I've
been sitting for a week like
you son of a now there were other
clues that have since been a minute and
what gave it away were all of the
credits firstly Don cheadle's name
appeared as being in the episode even
though my man never showed his face we
also get translated versions of these
entries with with voice actors dubbing
over lines from their English
counterparts and all of Don cheadle's
voice over artists read out the lines in
that scene this meant we could figure
out who's already on the phone and you
see kids that's how you know I'm not a
scroll yet because someone good they
would have caught that nerodi being a
scroll was pretty much the only
conclusion anyone could come to because
he's like the only actual Avenger in the
entire show the comic said them
replacing a number of the team but
obviously they haven't got the budget
here to bring in that cast thus we just
have Rory and Everett roster they can
replace here it was kind of obvious when
you look back at it I do think it will
be a recent switch over due to him
appearing in Falcon in the Winter
Soldier which happened quite recently
after the events of endgame Dowdy was a
scroll during that though in the first
Iron Man movie it does look slightly
different some some fishy going on there
now on top of this we can hear that Nick
Fury is listening in and as he said last
week he had an Intel at someone high up
in the US government was in fact a
scroll but are soda please for his life
yeah and she says that he's a broken man
and a shell of his former self man
sitting in his chair like Adam 22
listening to his wife putting him down
but the order from Rowdy it still goes
ahead now one thing a lot of you guys
have hit me up with is the fact that
Furrier he constantly takes his glasses
on and off as we saw in the first entry
these are similar to The Edith ones
where they can scan an environment and
detect certain details belt with an AI
in there and they add an extra layer of
surveillance and it's possible that
Fury's been using them to keep an eye on
people last week he set up barra's foe
when he was wearing them and this may
have been him scanning the data on it to
see who just called when meeting Rowdy
he also wore them as well and it's
possible that he sees them as a way to
detect certain things in an area now we
did catch him in his home watching the
fxn host which he brushed off as him
just keeping an eye on things how can
you watch that poison you're even a
broken clocks right twice a day
good morning also yeah whenever I say
fxm people are like it's if it's
actually Fox News
fxn in the show I'm not gonna go when
they go to the Fox News part just shut
the
now this actually might have been the
case if he was aware that the host was a
scroll him going to his wife was
something I echoed the comics too as in
those he did hook up with Val he ended
up following her to see what she was up
to and this is where it was revealed
that she was a spy he didn't expect her
to be a scroll but he did interrogate
her which is when he then shot and
killed her at this point she turned and
it just goes to show that there may have
been other reasons for why he returned
home a future that's a new rock stars
are pawning this out and it could
indicate there's two Nicks moving around
with one wearing glasses whilst the
other doesn't we have seen from the
trailers that there appeared to be two
different times Fury came down from
saber as we can see that he was wearing
different clothes not saying that could
confirm those two versions but it's
interesting how about these shots we're
used in the same way both appeared in
the trailer as a way to show Fury coming
to Earth so potentially that might have
been done as a little clue by the
creative team anyway from here we cut
the graphic telling Peg and that guy is
actually the mole the Peril launching
and attack disguised as the Russians and
this leads to a big action scene that
we'll talk about in just a bit now as
for Pagan he's a pretty big character in
the comics played by Killian Scott Pagan
was one of the first Scrolls Who
infiltrated The Avengers masquerading
his Electra for several missions he
perfectly slotted into the group without
arousing suspicion a pagan had taken on
the new form of scroll programming which
involved taking on the memories in DNA
of their specific Target you see in the
past telepaths and characters like
Wolverine could send Scrolls out by
either reading their minds or just
telling that they smell differently you
don't smell like dog this week
Beast however Pagan even managed to
bypass Spider-Man spider Sans and it was
on a mission to Earth to find an echo
that the cover finally dropped finding
echo in a brainwashed stage she then
stabbed elektraer which was when the
truth was revealed taken before Tony
Stark this is when The Invasion became
apparent and it was through Pagan that
everything came down he was sent in on
that Mega Dangerous Mission and this
married how the team was sent to the sub
last week now interestingly we know that
the scrolls are taking the memories of
the people that they're imitating even
though we know Robert Fairbank had a
scroll imitating him this still seemed
to be quite attached to the real
Robertson Zachary he didn't want Fury
killing him and even hugged him after he
was let go potentially these memories
are like the theory that people have on
organ donation where they say that you
take on some of the traits from the
person that you got the organ from
getting someone's memories might make
that person care for what they love and
this might even explain why graphic
likes dogs we saw as he arrived in
Brixton and we know Kingsley benediers
also from London too makes sense that
he'd have the accent he does and
potentially copied someone from around
the area now from here we joined talas
and Gaia meeting on a bench with him
showing remorse over drafting her into a
war whether he likes to admit it or not
he was the one in cosine Fury and this
brought Scrolls to the planet that ended
up acting as spies for him he obviously
couldn't tell the future but still the
people in their abilities have been
weaponized in the surveillance he's
carried out Talos regrets forcing Gaia
into it but she says she did it of her
own free will due to the death of her
mother she now wants to be closer to her
dad but she needs him to have a counter
plan that will appeal to the people
obviously they'll follow gravic to their
Oblivion otherwise unless he needs to
have an idea that's gonna win them round
now tell us believes showing that there
are good Scrolls who make Humanity give
the millions of them a place to live but
I don't know if you're overestimating
our generosity now he's clearly playing
another quote-unquote good immigrant
idea which makes up a lot of social
studies in case you don't know this is
basically the idea that people will be
welcomed into a country that isn't their
home as long as they're useful and stick
to the culture and rules it's some yet
been studied in depth and it of course
examines things like racism and
Prejudice to discuss whether acting like
this will ever actually be good enough
it's way too in-depth the discuss in a
breakdown like this but guy out rightly
criticizes the idea and kindly shuts it
down it's not going to bring them any
true safety and it's highly unlikely
that this will actually work the Scrolls
don't want to be forced to remain in the
shadows which they would have to be and
Talos clearly fails to even convince her
we can't convince hey he's gonna have
difficulty with the others and yeah
there's definitely a lot of things to
talk about now apologies if if I've kind
of rushed over the the idea as it's a
very sensitive subject and yeah if you
took something different or just thought
my interpretation was wrong then let me
know below now from here we go back to
Vera returning to her home on the wall
we can catch several masks and these are
of course symbolic of the faces the
Scrolls wear Nick's wedding ring is
there but he is in the house showing
that he's now stepped away from how he
views her as his wife this is something
that he took off to hide the fact that
he had one and this was so people
couldn't weaponize her as a way to get
to him symbolically in the home though
he wore it to show they were together
but him taking it off clearly shows he
doesn't trust her now one thing you
might have noticed about Vera that
played her hand a bit in the show was
how they literally played her hand when
she first introduced kravik we could see
she was wearing a wedding ring and then
come episode 3 she wore at the star too
this was in the flashback in which he
met up with Theory and due to her having
it early I'm guessing it's scroll
jewelry now in the present she's
completely missing this which could be
symbolic for a number of reasons mayhand
how she's no longer a fury and this
could be seen as being a wedding ring
however if it's scroll jewelry then it
may be how she stepped away from them
and we have had hints towards what's
happening with her in the trailers got
in trouble last week for saying that
they'd shown Guyer alive so I'll try and
keep that stuff to a minimum going
forward but yeah there are certain Clues
now Fury confronts her and tells her
that he knows she's been instructed to
kill him but he doesn't know if he
changed anything about their life it's a
flipping love if you will and varadival
just that she mimicked a doctor named
Priscilla with a heart effect who would
appeal to Fury now the doctor kept it
the secret and she didn't want people
around her knowing that she was gonna
die we've seen cases of this in real
life is specially connected to Marvel
and shadwick Boseman of course kept his
cancer quieter everyone but those
extremely close to him not saying it was
implemented for that reason but some
people just decided to live their life
without people worrying about them she
asked if she could take over the
person's life in the wake of their death
and this would keep up the appearance
that she was still alive she made three
promises off the back of this which is
that she'd bury her at Sea be a daughter
to her parents and also never hurt Nick
we learned that Vara told her about Nick
directly and she said that she would
make her go on to feel loved now this of
course is playing off the poem earlier
in which Carver said that he felt
beloved and thus he had a meaningful
life the doctor didn't get to do this
but getting someone to mimic her was
somewhat a second chance in which she
would feel Beloved the poem is brought
up once more with biryan Vara quoting it
directly now they missed her and Mrs
Smith each other and both purposely
missed because they were willing to let
the other win and not feel bad for
shooting them that's how much they cared
and they didn't want the other thinking
their Meadow was unjust but them both
missing then cement sale up now as the
gunshots ring throughout the house we
actually see a book by Vara recording
how the Superhuman Gene Works clearly
she has gone on to study this and it
might actually be our Scrolls managed to
create the formula as for super Scrolls
these are basically your super soldiers
when it comes to their species we've had
this being a motif that's popped up a
lot in the MCU and both Captain America
and Hulk were created through this we've
got us agent in the flag smashes as well
along with the characters featuring a
new world order we know from d23 that
the leader will be in a two and if
Harrison Ford becomes the Red Hulk then
that's gonna mix things up as well now
it's possible that the squirrels have
been studying this too and as we saw in
the scientists whiteboard they have been
studying human DNA this could
potentially tine with extremis though
which we know is making up their super
scroll formula Anika makes the first one
was called clert and he mimicked the
powers of the Fantastic Four first
introduced in fantastic 418 we saw that
they achieved power set through the use
of science with their powers he actually
managed to beat the Fantastic Four in
their first fight Annie was seen as one
of their greatest foes obviously as
though things have been done differently
and they upped their tactics in the
run-up to secret Invasion rather than
just copying their powers they copy the
hero's entire DNA and this allowed them
to mimic their targets even better if
you think about it big reason they'd
quickly get caught out is because like
say a scroll was pretending to be a hero
that could fly they'd give themselves
away as soon as it was take off however
work on the super Scrolls allowed them
to adapt beyond that and they were able
to blend in perfectly now it seems that
graphic is more of a prototype and that
will get super Scrolls that are more in
line with the comics I'm guessing
they've skipped this because the
Fantastic Four on in the MCU yeah and
hopefully fingers crossed we find out
who's playing them very soon however
they have managed to mimic the Fantastic
Four Powers pretty well with them having
basically the Aldi version of their
powers you've got extremis instead of
Johnny Storm and instead of Mr a
fantastic the characters can stretch
because of Groot strength is covered by
color in the frost beasts and yeah it
does kind of line up though we don't get
to storm Powers unfortunately now if I
asked Fury directly if he'd loved her if
he was looking at her real face and it's
clear that he struggles over the center
he says I'll guess we'll never know but
I think deep down here it would have
always been in the back of your mind you
can shallow harness all you want but
you'd know me you'd know now if you're
questioning whether you'd be down for
some scroll love we cut to one in the
shower witch
would I would you know anyway this is
the Roadie scroll and he finds Nick
waiting for him I wouldn't do them as
Don Cheadle yeah just just to clarify
that no it's very sort of James bondian
with him already knowing the truth and
him basically just playing with his food
it sort of mirrors the prior scene with
pharah and the scene that Fury had with
this scroll in the restaurant Fury bus
had a bottle of Pappy Van Winkle namely
the 23 year old one which means that
it's just in the age bracket that
Leonardo DiCaprio would enjoy it I had a
look at this one on Google mate
specifically five grand in the UK in us
for a bottle and man display he's bloody
causing me a heart attack thinking that
he's gonna spill it don't don't spill it
now what makes it so rare is that it's
age longer than most bourbons and The
Distillery that produces it does very
limited quantities it's difficult to get
your hands on but Rory Scrolls of course
worry that it's been poisoned and it
keeps playing at their race and how they
should be bonding with each other which
is something that the scroll weaponized
against him during that restaurant scene
he was constantly talking about how they
had to outdo mediocre white men and it
was clearly the scroll trying to play
fury to make it seem like they were on
the same side I love Samuel L Jackson in
this moment and him smoking as he tells
him there's squirrels in the US
government it did crack me up a bit he's
just playing with him but the scroll
fires back when he shows a recording of
Graphics shooting Maria Hill Roddy knows
that if he exposes the scroll and it's
gonna cause issues so what he has to do
is expose him instead the scrolls are
Masters at blackmail into seed but him
doing this is clearly a step too far now
Fury leaves without causing first but we
learn what the true goal of this
conversation was and placed a liquid
tracking device and it allows viewing
Talos to then go and follow him down the
streets we actually start to see as
anti-war protests are beginning to mount
up the world is obviously on the brink
of a major conflict and the president's
flow now in order to negotiate said to
be the most important negotiation since
the Cuban Missile Crisis they wanted to
draw him out and then launch the attack
now rolly clearly smells like bourbon
and he begins rattling off quotes like
you make when he's drunk also I love how
one of the guys says his almond is
slaying and this is of course who Fury
disarmed at the restaurant
now last week you might remember that I
accused Ryan Arie from screen Crush of
being a scroll
my lawyers have advised me not to say
anything about it
but they didn't say I couldn't sing
[Music]
so I'd like to
Jazz for what I said
cause Ryan is ended up dead heavy
spoiler fans found him and crushed his
head
and I'm sorry Ryan
they thought that he might be a scroll
so they tracked him down and bashed in
his skull so I'd like to apologize for
the crime cause all it was was a theory
time
now the attack on the Convoy is a big
thing that's been shown in the trailers
and I'm guessing that this is going to
be the major action scene in the entire
series kind of crazy I think we have
just two episodes left and if there's a
bigger moment than this then it hasn't
been teased yet now getting to Ritz in
is of course their big goal and in the
comics they actually replaced President
Barack Obama where this goes in the
future we also kind of know because
Harrison Ford will be playing president
Ross that should have happened in
Captain America New World Order with him
probably using the series as a
springboard for his own gains in the
comics it was Norman Osborne who took
out the Scrolls and this allowed him to
become the director of Shield all the
good publicity gained from it gave him a
blank checkbook and he slowly started to
put everything into place he was the one
who became the Iron Patriot and he also
starred a group known as the dark
Avengers I think that they may mirror
this with Ross but he'll create the
Thunderbolts instead he also won't
become the Iron Patriot he'll become the
Red Hulk and then we'll get a similar
thing to what played out in the ark he
either way the attack is big and over
the top but it actually works as a way
to demonstrate that there are good
Scrolls Telus gets himself deep into the
fight and even sacrifices himself in
order to save the president now the
death of Talos actually has a roots in
Greek mythology with Plato being the one
that really helped to give it meaning
there are several different ways that it
said the figure died but all of these
are chalked up to being by Medea in one
version she gave Talos poison that
caused him to go insane and in the other
she had spells that made him fall to his
death either way the Legends say that
his Divine blood was spelled and this
had a massive change in Greek mythology
now one thing that's consistent across
all the Legends is that Talos is seen as
being from a Pastime whether he's a
leftover from the Bronze Age or a scroll
he represents the old ways I think it's
been pulled across to this to reflect
the Legends now whether he's dead or not
remains to be seen but I think it would
be bad to have two death fake outs back
to back like this I did think they'd
bring Maria Hill back but I think after
the whole guy thing that keeping her
dead is probably the more impactful way
to go about it either way this fight
clearly demonstrates the power of the
super Scrolls and the fact that they can
shapeshift makes them infinitely more
dangerous Fury also bursts at a rocket
launcher at one point and we did see the
character using one of these in The
Avengers the desperate to say written as
well as this will avert the war and
gravic using his powers clearly shows
that it's not the Russians loved seeing
and bust out roots arming and crushed
someone but it does kind of in the end
give the game away now the world will be
aware that there are Scrolls and
potentially they'll unite to fight this
common enemy Fury can convince the
president of the truth and tell us
inadvertently may bring Humanity
together through his sacrifice even
after being shot he still Powers through
the pain to free the president and it's
possible that he could have actually
survived this of our graphic disguise
himself as a soldier and he stabs him
leaving him for dead he also
demonstrates that he has the power of
extremis which means that Fury's gonna
have to step it up a notch in order to
be able to match him now we close out on
talus's body similar to Maria and all in
all it was a pretty noble way for the
character to go his legacy will of
course be carried on by his daughter but
yeah this was a death that kind of
bummed me out a huge thank you to
everyone for following the videos and
channel and if you want to support us
and get something back we've just
launched a secret Invasion slash Pulp
Fiction t-shirt that's over at our merch
store shop zeroedition.com and look at
it we've got Nick Furious Jewels here
and Talos he's doing bloody John
Travolta Vincent Vega I think it was no
huge anyway huge thank you to everyone
who's got one so far much love and thank
you for supporting this spoiler Invasion
and that wraps up the episode and a huge
thank you for joining me again I am kind
of having a weird time with the show
cause I seem to be one of the only
people actually enjoying it but the the
main criticism I'm seeing is that this
series is just too boring I don't know
I've always I've always sort of liked
these Espionage type Thrillers you know
tinga Taylor soldiers bye I I know that
isn't fair everyone but as someone who
loved that film I think this fits that
tone perfectly now obviously we've hit a
point now where the mcu's branching out
into other genres and depending on what
your likes gonna massively affect your
enjoyment for example I don't really
like the joke heavy stuff but I prefer
the stuff that takes itself more
seriously one of my favorite Marvel
movies is the Winter Soldier and I feel
like the series stays in the tone of
that now I'm not saying that the other
stuff shouldn't be made I think there
shouldn't just be one term for
everything but yeah I grew up with DC as
a well Batman is a kid so that that's
where I tend to lean so yeah I'm
enjoying it and another criticism I've
seen is that this should probably be a
movie actually kind of agree too and it
is weird that they diverted so heavily
from the comics secret invasion was his
Avengers level thing where a lot of the
heroes got replaced Razia even though
it's you know World War III I think that
might be the wrong way to describe it
because like I said it's world war three
but it it doesn't feel like it's got
that extra level to it you know what I
mean now according to the rumors the the
early workings of the script actually
had this being the plot for Captain
Marvel 2 and as we know this eventually
evolved into the Marvels I did see
people saying that this would kind of go
from the end of Captain Marvel with a
whole home plot and then go from there
however stuff got changed and it was
reworked into a series but I can't help
thinking what could have potentially
been either way I'm enjoying the series
and for me it's probably up there in
terms of favorites I don't know whether
I preferred overlooky or not but I can
say that I am enjoying it obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click that join button yet Early
Access to videos every week there goes
such a long way honestly it goes such a
long way to helping us out hope you want
something else to watch then check out
Deadpool 3 leaks breakdown which will be
linked on screen right now talk about
some of the cameos also the big plot
leaks so yeah definitely head over there
right after this other way huge thank
you for singing through the video I'll
Be Paul even the best I'll see you next
time take care peace